hello there
so fortnite chapter 2 season 5 released
and just like every other fortnight
season before it
it's packed with a smorgasbord of
glitches and
bugs some of these are harmless fun some
are totally
weird and some give an unfair advantage
and some
will get you banned i've compiled the 10
most broken
and downright amusing ones for you to
try for yourself
so let's do this oh self-promotion use
code adam arrow please
for extra i don't know waffles in your
life
does that convince you oh well let's do
this
so i'm sure by now you've tried to stand
on the zero point
am i right it's a pretty good spot
actually is good viewpoint decent angles
and a quick way to escape to well have
you tried taking a vehicle
into the zero point recently
mechanically it's a strange thing to see
because the cars aren't able to pass
through the zero point
and instead the passengers are thrown
through the orb while the ride sits and
waits
now do this from the top and everything
changes
as expected the passengers are thrown
through the vortex of time and space
but the car stays on top levitating
happily
it's now possible to climb back up and
get back in the vehicle
i have no idea why you'd want to do this
but those sight lines are great
and this bonding moment between
teammates is unrivalled
let's be honest here if you haven't
danced in the back of a pickup truck
on the zero point in season five do you
even fortnight bro
okay that was a fun one let's change to
a glitch which could change your entire
game
this is the unlimited harpoon glitch
it's possible to fish with this item
and never lose a charge you could loot
for days
for this glitch to work you will need a
full inventory and of course a harpoon
you'll also need an extra item which
we'll be switching to so get your butt
down to a fishing hole
and juggle the other item down there too
here's the setup
you'll need to aim the harpoon at the
fishing spot but also make sure the
extra item you brought
is only one click away now pick up the
item and just at the split second it
would replace your current item
use the harpoon if done perfectly not
only will you have a newly fished item
but you'll also keep that harpoon charge
there's no limit to this this can be
done as many times as you can get this
right
but i'm sure it will be patched at some
point the timing can be awkward but
after a few attempts you'll feel the
pattern
and enjoy these moist goodies so that
one can legitimately change your game
let's do something which doesn't at all
all around the island are npcs to
interact with
fyi kyle is here so i decided to become
the big man because he isn't out in the
store just yet
using mystique and her unique ability
and this works on all npcs throughout
this world
allowing us to try before we buy in some
cases
well now for the glitch get your
buttocks over to maeve
and take her out now use mystique's
ability to steal her identity
here's the glitch simply jump into the
water
usually maeve has the ability to morph
into animals
in water that's a shark's tail but check
this version of maeve out she's
different
her tail does not exist at all i'm lost
for words
but i kind of like this i'm unsure if
this happens because i haven't unlocked
her morphing ability yet in the battle
pass
or if this is a gift for everyone rest
assured it will be perched so if you
want to cosplay as a warrior mannequin
now's your time to shine she's over by
the boat graveyard on the east of the
map
season five brought us the colosseum but
this place is actually indestructible
unlike most other pois unbreakable
structures
always leads to peculiar shenanigans one
of which
is so easy to recreate that everyone is
doing this
at this location so you need to be very
aware within each of the four corners of
the coliseum it's possible to get
out of bounds by simply walking up a
ramp
that's it nothing more just one ramp
needed for this
it's only a single one by one tile but
it becomes a secret nest
to watch others because they can't see
you whilst you're up here you can even
take cheeky shots and knock down their
builds
to get more out of this spot place down
and edit a floor tile and break away
your ramp
you now have a dirty stinking cheetah
room enjoy yourself
from the other person's perspective it's
close to impossible to notice
so see this as a way to watch out for
those glitches and be prepared for
certain attacks
[Music]
for our next bunch of glitches we're
going to look at sand tunneling
it just came back this morning so i can
actually capture this footage now
i'm sure you've tried tunneling and
you've got sand in your flip-flops
did you know though there are some areas
which are totally broken when it comes
to sand tunneling
for example we can smash ourselves into
different items whilst we're under the
sand
we'll try that on this old slurp truck
and you'll be in for a surprise okay
it's not really a wow surprise but hey
the texture
is slapped off the truck without a
reason at
all can anyone make out where this
texture is from
could it be a clue or could it be just a
glitch yes
yeah it's just a glitch staying
underground you'll notice that it's
actually possible to be a land hump
under a few of the roads the best one is
here by salty towers
and my personal favorite if you go
towards objects which are low in the
ground like a fence
it's possible to slowly move up them and
make your hump in the sand
more of a ball going too fast or too far
breaks this stretching of the rules
this is my current biggest sand boulder
i challenge you to break my pointless
world record
whoever has the biggest balls wins i
guess either
sorry taking your sandy self through
water and you'll be thrown out instantly
but there is a way to circumvent that
over in salty there is a house which is
slightly filled with water
if you get under the stairs it's
possible to start tunneling again
but this time you can go underwater
in terms of a hiding spot this is
impossible to see
the water haze on top and the objects
here make this a top
quality hiding spot the only downside is
when you actually do
leave the water you'll be ejected from
your tunneling oh that reminds me one
last one about sand snaking
have you ever noticed how long it takes
to jump out of the sand before firing a
shot
it's sizeable enough for your enemy to
notice and one pump you in the face
but there's actually a little neat trick
you can use by switching your weapon
when you're under the sand at the same
moment you intend to jump out
you'll actually cancel the jump
animation and instead be able to stand
and fire
instantly this is criminally op so
definitely use it
and if you don't want to use it be aware
of it
as is now a tradition in fortnite when
the new season drops we all figure out
how to get back home to spawn island
this time around it isn't as hard as the
helicarrier but a similar method must be
used to get there
you'll either need a boat or a car and
about 3 000 mats
to get back to spawn island by land
you'll need to build a bridge
all the way until you hit the invisible
barrier now you'll need a partner in
crime
vehicles can actually break through this
barrier so as long as you're inside the
vehicle you can get through this
one person will slowly drive forward
whilst the other builds a road in front
of them
by the way the person driving the car
will have a dreadful point of view so
don't rush this
eventually you'll feel confident enough
that you're on home turf
and you can swim to the island the
barrier remains there so you won't be
able to get back
unless you've got enough gas
alternatively use a boat
simply drive until you hit the barrier
then slow up point your boat in the
right direction
and simply switch seats the boat will
suddenly chug into action
and get you all the way back to spawn
island it just takes a long while
and now a returning glitch from a few
seasons back and it's here again in
season five
underwater driving around the map you'll
see loads of shallow areas of water in
which you can do this but like usual
there's a best spot which is up by the
bridge here
by taking a vehicle into the water
you'll eventually be kicked out when it
gets too deep
now's the time to repeatedly get back in
your car until the game doesn't kick you
out anymore
something glitchy's out here and
depending on how this went for you
the cars will now start to shake and
judder
it's really strange this will continue
randomly with all vehicles you get in so
be aware of that when you're trying to
fill your car up and it's dancing in
front of your eyes
anyway the best thing about this is that
you can now drive underwater without
being kicked out
and you will not drown you can stay here
for as long as you like
the only thing you have to worry about
is the fuel gauge
but to be serious you should be
questioning why you are doing this and
what has your life become
like like i'm thinking right now
so there we have it ten funny peculiar
downright cheaty glitches in fortnite
season five
i was not the first person to find these
glitches orange guy glitch king
cold slide and tons of others found most
of this stuff way before me
but i'm not sure which one to credit so
let's give them all some love and
subscribe to them if glitches are your
thing
on screen now are more code adamaru
legends who sent me a twitter dm with
proof of what they grabbed in the store
and in return i say thanks by showcasing
their names here
thank you very much i truly appreciate
you i'm adam from playstation grenade
you're awesome i'll see you next time
[Music]
you